and now ladies and gentlemen say that
Aggie and dis year's recipient off their
freedom of speech about DW is freedom of
speech award recognizes independent
journalism in places where critical
reporting is dangerous this year's
winner is to that again editor of
turkeys independent daily newspaper puri
yet he's a courageous fighting for
freedom of press and the other reason is
that looking at turkey makes us really
anxious concerning freedom and values
because nearly every journalist who is
only a bit critical to the government as
being prosecuted as being tied to the
cords again is facing charges that he
insulted Turkey's president wretched
tire burdwan critics accuse the
president of using defamation lawsuits
like this one to restrict freedom of
speech Turkey has slipped to position
151 of 180 countries in reporters
without borders rating of international
press freedom ergen's newspaper hurry it
has itself been subjected to repeated
attacks from earlier one supporters
Juliet means freedom currently this name
is not a description of reality it is
rather a reminder of and a hope for
better times as long as it at Argan and
his courageous editors continue their
work and will not be silenced I do not
want to give up my hope that there will
be better times in turkey again what was
in the free speech is not always
comfortable for audiences again used his
acceptance speech to criticize the
German parliament decision to recognize
as genocide the 1915 massacre of
Armenians by the Ottoman Empire Ergen
called it a disappointment for Turkey
and for him personally there is a need
for reconciliation between the two
neighboring nations but as a resolution
a solution adapted as such by the
bundestag would only have a
counterproductive effect on such efforts
needless to say the resolution be
adversely effectively
within Turkey in Germany but that
disagreement didn't stop him from
traveling to germany to join two
thousand other media decision makers for
the global media forum it's a clear sign
he'd rather stand up for his beliefs
then hold back his opinions